Arlie quit wasting time you stupid mug  we need poison ivy and got them now if  our plan to destroy Batman is gonna work  walking by train and remember I'm only  helping you and scarecrow do this tech  child be man my boy touch a nerve did I  good now hurry up and find Ivy I know we  should have said what about men to do  this job arto scarecrows went double  trouble I should get out of the way  where's it coming from  okay I'm impressed by the way ahead of  yourself back there okay we'll use a  girl like you and my organization oh oh  how much to get you all pay well your  puddin is Pushing Daisies queen and all  the Wonder work for now keep it quiet  you don't want to attract too much  attention  you bar with you or check to see if  these coppers got ID on the wire just  get to the computer and find are they  come on let's finish this thing before  you upset scarecrow  you